although she received her friendly
French welcome in Paris it wasn't easy
going for tourism a president Emanuel
Matt corn is often seen as the European
leader with the toughest demands May was
lucky this time
France softened its stance and said at
the lay within limits was an option for
the long-awaited brexit still France and
other European countries are getting
increasingly impatient we want to
understand what the UK need this
extension for and what is the political
surroundings around syriza may to have
this extension before her visit to Paris
may travel to Berlin to ask German
Chancellor Angela Merkel about the
extension but like many brexit
arrangements things didn't quite go as
planned to resume arrived a little too
early and Merkel wasn't there to welcome
her after the meeting Merkel said brexit
could be extended to the beginning of
2020 but many European leaders are
urging the British to provide more
clarity this was the call on Tuesday
morning at a meeting of EU foreign
ministers via we are waiting finally for
substantive steps in the right direction
up to now nothing at all has changed we
are of course thinking about an
appropriate extension of the deadline
and also about a longer extension they
must however come with very strict
conditions guns
Italian with official visits to Berlin
and Paris completed to resume now has to
brace herself for the upcoming emergency
summit in Brussels for the very latest
let's bring in our Brussels
correspondent band Liga and DWS Berg at
mass in London first - you vant tell us
are the EU member states united on
giving Teresa may more time to get the
breaks that deal approved because just a
couple of days ago some like France
we're sounding very reluctant no other
stands now the EU is very United and
also very very patient
with Great Britain because the you does
not want to take the blame for No Deal
heart brexit for Britain crashing out of
the you this is not our decision said
that you negotiate a Michel Barnier
and so missus may will offered will be
offered a long extension nine or twelve
months but Britain can leave at any
point but there are two conditions
attached first Britain has to take part
in the European elections and of may and
Britain has to grant a kind of a sincere
cooperation in this extended period this
is a kind of a if you will say so a
backstop for the EU this time to prevent
any future Prime Minister to obstruct EU
business and to prevent a spill over of
the chaos from the islands to the
continent okay so a couple of conditions
there are being put forth in Brussels
over to you Birgit EU leaders have said
that any further extension the brakes at
deadline also depends on London
presenting a clear purpose for an
extension does Teresa may have a clear
purpose or just a vague hope that
Parliament will eventually make up its
mind it's really more a vague hope at
this point she is talking to the
opposition to the Labour Party and those
talks are continuing but it's actually
far from easy to reach a consensus
because there isn't really a tradition
here in the UK to work together to
cooperate across party line so that
makes it quite tricky also for Teresa
may herself she is really not in a very
secure position we've had people from
from her own party asking for a change
in the in the party manifesto so that
there could be another leadership
challenge they don't want to see Teresa
may for them taking part in the European
elections like ban mention and staying
longer in the u.s. absolute anathema so
really a lot is still up in the air at
the moment and Teresa mais position
herself is really not stable at all
bigots mass in London and in Brussels
for us that bounty
thank you very much to you both well
it's been almost three years since the
UK decided in a referendum to leave the
European Union but why did Britain's
boat the way they did here's a look back
the UK has voted to leave the European
Union these words left about 52% of
Great Britain ecstatic and the other 48%
in shock not least Prime Minister David
Cameron his Conservative Party and the
British people at large had always been
divided over Europe
Cameron gambled on a referendum to
settle this question and assumed Britain
would remain in the EU on the 24th of
January dude thank you very much
but he was wrong the leave campaign led
by Nigel Faraj and the UK Independence
Party fed the fears of migration and
open borders and this at the height of
the European migration crisis others
like former London Mayor Boris Johnson
used false promises to convince Britons
that there was no other way than to
leave the EU it's our last chance to
sort this out and take back control if
we if we don't vote to leave tomorrow
we'll remain locked in the back of the
car driven in an uncertain direction
frankly to a place we don't want to go
and perhaps by a driver who doesn't
speak the very best of Englishman the
traditionally Euroskeptic British media
was also in the game many newspapers
actively campaigning for a leave vote on
top of that came a general dislike for a
European Union perceived a slow
bureaucratic expensive and dominated by
Germany and France the moment we got so
many bureaucrats in Europe telling us
exactly what we've got to do and when
we've got to do it and
I don't think we rate was govern our own
country anymore to be honest we'll have
more money cuz we really paying so much
the EU and it'll unleash great
entrepreneurial forces within the
country we should be great for an
average is Britain so really we should
get the great back and sort of self out
really lose you mean after the
referendum the levers celebrated the
victory of their lives and the man who
set the ball rolling resigned so we'll
have a new prime minister in that
building behind me by Wednesday evening
thank you very much leaving it to others
to try to reverse more than 40 years of
political and economic Union
[Music]